des divisions qui ressemble à un
sabordage en pleine tempête médiatique
et social le gouvernement et la majorité
se déchire depuis plusieurs jours suite
aux propos du ministre de l'économie
bruno le maire parue dans le parisien
vendredi
ce dernier souhaite faire de la réforme
des retraites
sa priorité absolue l'an prochain et y
voit un moyen économique de rembourser
la dette abyssale de l'état l'état
remboursera sa dette d'abord grâce au
retour de la croissance
ensuite par une maîtrise de nos dépenses
de fonctionnement et enfin par des
réformes structurelles comme celle des
retraites qui doit être la priorité
absolue c'est une conviction forte des
propos salués par le leader du mouvement
de la république en marche stanislas
guérini qui juge le chantier essentiel
dans l'ambition de transformation du
pays
un enthousiasme qui s'est violemment
heurté à la ministre du travail
elisabeth bornes et au ministre des
relations avec le parlement
marc fesneau la priorité absolue c'est
de sortir de la crise sanitaire
économique social de protéger les
emplois c'est l'avis unanime des
partenaires sociaux la réforme des
retraites telle qu'elle avait été posée
c'était une réforme qui vise à avoir
plus de justice et l'anglais sur la
question budgétaire ne me paraît à ce
stade pas la question
un désaccord sur la priorité est le sens
à donner à cette réforme qui avait été
adopté grâce à l'article 49 3 en
première lecture à l'assemblée nationale
et qui a été pour l'instant mis de côté
ciné dié en raison de la crise sanitaire
face à la réapparition du dossier la
présidente du rassemblement national
marine le pen y voit de son côté la main
de bruxelles dans le contexte actuel
qu'est ce qui peut sérieusement
justifier que la réforme des retraites
soit une priorité absolue bruno le maire
qui exige cela de vous
la commission en contrepartie du plan de
relance dit la vérité aux français
enfin pour les syndicats pas question de
voir la question des retraites
réapparaître au risque de provoquer
un nouveau conflit social un argument
qui fera à coup sûr réfléchir l'elysée
qui voit les contestations sociales et
sanitaires se multiplier depuis
plusieurs jours